yesterday neural link tweeted we're
excited to share that we have received
the fda's approval to launch our first
inhuman clinical study this is the
result of incredible work blah blah blah
we Greta we get it recruitment is not
yet open for our clinical trial we'll
announce more information on this soon
that's right we are getting very close
to the point where they're going to ask
humans to submit to neuralink implants
now
for the time being it is read only
and that's still okay
basically what they can do uh what I was
reading is that there's very thin uh
like copper wires or whatever that they
can lay on like the nerves and then
start to absorb information and then
decode and I think they were able to
track like vital signs of pigs or
something I don't know that they've done
any kind of uh real neural link remote
control of a person however organic
remote control already exists they've
done this in cockroaches I believe in
rats what they do with mammals is they
can put in an implant which interferes
with equilibrium
and so they make the animal feel like
it's falling over and then it has to run
in that direction so if you start
leaning forward your body reacts and you
try to write yourself up
it's called balance they can manipulate
that so you'll feel like you're falling
backwards and try and start walking
forward to try and counteract it because
it's it it's almost painful it's not
like trying to resist you're like it's
almost like torture I think vertigo so
they can do this they can do that now
with neuralink the scary thing is going
to be once they get to the point where
they can write to your brain I don't
know
how far off that is it may be very very
far away so like putting thoughts in
your yes yeah who is signing up for
these studies it's not it doesn't have
to be thoughts all it has to be is just
a little bit of Serotonin a little bit
of dopamine they can do that now that
you don't need knurling yeah with the
with phones and stuff but when when no
no no I mean like they can put an
implant in your brain you don't need
neuralink to connect and read data from
your brain just we've done it with rats
a long time ago they did that experiment
where the racket press a button and get
a dopamine hit and so just matching the
button when I was talking to the guy
from white coat uh waste project earlier
man the stuff they do with animals is
scary I don't know if you guys might not
want to watch that culture War episode
because it's like talking about the
horrible things they do to animals but
if you don't like fauci you probably
should watch it because it'll make it
not like a more
they talk about how they yeah puppies I
don't even want to I don't even want to
say it man because people are going to
get mad but let me just tell you the The
Psychotic things they do for no reason
it's just like there's evil people just
to see it's like mad scientists I'm
gonna I'm gonna say it because we've
covered it before and I'm pissed off
they take beagles and this is funding
under fauci and they would put a net
around a part of the beagle and then put
starved sand flies in it so the Flies
would eat the dog alive and it's like
why I want to see what happened
that was one of the stories that we we
uh talked about was they put hamsters on
steroids and then made them fight
and I'm like I hear that I start
laughing and I'm like you're getting
like they spent a million dollars to put
hamsters on steroids and make them fight
as I'm busting out laughing and then I
watched the video and I got really angry
yeah cause like you're imagining
hamsters and they're like buffing them
up and then you watch the video and it's
it's it's really what is their
explanation for why they think that is
necessary
some of it does make sense some of it is
like we are testing a new methodology
for treating wounds and something we're
like okay we get it but the problem is
so much of this stuff is literally just
like please don't fire me I need a grant
and so and and the government is funding
this stuff I don't want to go off on
that tangent when it comes to the issue
of Nora link my point is simply that
we've done the studies on animals where
we can control their brains I brought it
up because he told me that they did this
thing where they hooked up IVs to I
think monkeys that fed them nicotine and
then they could press a button to get a
nicotine hit and it's just like man the
stuff they can do to people the stuff
they've learned when it comes to norlink
the moment they can write things into
your brain
they they can then say to you Taylor why
are you so how about I'm being an
activist you know wouldn't you rather
just go into your own Universe where you
are X Games gold medalist here just just
just plug in check this out try it one
time you plug in and then all of a
sudden you're in this universe where
they can simulate feelings and people
and it's AI generated and they and right
when they plug you in they walk up to
you and say you just won Gold at The X
game Street Taylor what do you have to
say to all of your fans and you're there
and you can feel it like you're really
there so many people are gonna say
I give up give me that see I feel like
I'd turn that down I like the the
realness of this okay okay wait I'll one
up one up here but it would feel real
you're you are on vacation or let's just
say one day you're sleeping and you wake
up
everything seemingly normal
and then you check your phone and you
got an email and it's like hey we're
inviting you to the X Games to compete
and you're like whoa really and then you
they're like yeah can you fly out and
you're like yes and so you go about your
life like normal and you fly out and
then you win and then what you don't
realize is Tim's making me sound like a
way better skateboarder than I am right
now what you don't realize is that or
maybe an AI I am because you were
disruptive to the ESG machine While You
Were Sleeping they plugged you in and
you never knew I wish this was just a
horror movie spot and not a potential
reality well the vrs and then here's the
best part when people are like whatever
happened to Taylor they'll be like oh
she she went to metaverse yeah she
totally bought she's gone no they're
like no she's right here like you wanna
you wanna see what she's up to like she
didn't go anywhere she's just chilling
in a pod yep and they're gonna be like
here she signed off on on joining
neuralink and she's living out her
dreams of being the best skater in the
world okay and people are gonna be like
wow I can't believe anyone ever says I
want in a metaverse it's a lie I did not
consent so this is change the subject a
little bit but uh I think James Lindsay
is listening tonight because he's re he
just tweeted something about the uh
Wisconsin LGBT Chamber of Commerce this
is from 2016. Harley Davidson is the
newest Platinum founding member of the
LGBT chamber
so I mean it's you know like I said it's
a little old but you know we're talking
about ESG and um and Harley-Davidson
well there's your answer
yeah so if you if you ride
Harley-Davidsons
you are like if you're if you're a man
who enjoys engaging in adult relations
other men Harley Davidson's the brand
for you it's uh it's not supposed to be
funny I'm you know y'all Gotta Laugh I
mean seriously I'm like that's the
that's the brand message they're
creating and I'm like that's cool like I
don't know I gotta I got an electric
motorcycle it's fun it's cool it's too
dangerous though and that's why I've
never used it fast yeah it's insanely
fast and that makes no sound yeah and so
it's just like yeah I don't know about
all that yeah I'm still laughing about
what you said before the show what I
don't wanna I don't want to steal it but
about how this is gonna be great for
like the Judas Priest lovers
fan base uh not not not really I like
food is free so I'm not hating look I'm
one of the biggest Jews priest fans
there is so I'm not judging at all but
you know Rob's got that look yeah he's
like uh he's also got that lifestyle
yeah so it's a cool band
they're the great one of the greatest
heavy metal bands of all time they're
into like gay motorcycle stuff
well you don't have to be gay elections
of course not that like that was before
everything was all political and pick a
side and All or Nothing everything you
know you know but the problem is I think
like what didn't Maynard he was in drag
is that what is that what Maynard did
that in Florida yeah they're doing this
because they're like haha these bigots
don't like dragons like dude we don't
care we don't want the kids there yeah
like bro if you want to do direct I
don't care what you do like I don't
I don't think anyone would have cared if
Target would have put out some like gay
Flag t-shirts it was when they started
making the baby onesies
no I think the pride stuff would have
sparked a negative reaction anyway yeah
I don't think it would have been as
extreme I do really yeah I don't think I
don't it's the the talking onesies
swimsuits well yeah that's that's a bit
extreme but the issue is that a guy has
got a man and woman you know in their
early 30s have a couple kids they're
young kids they walk in to go grocery
shopping they see this stuff and they
immediately whoa turn the kids around
and they're like I'm not ready to
explain to my six-year-old kid what this
stuff means totally when you when my son
says what does gay mean he's like let me
ex I gotta talk about the birds and the
bees now like that's they're not old
enough for this stuff we're not we're
not putting stuff where it's like
there may be things they argue about
there's all this straight propaganda and
straight it's like dude a man and a
woman together in an ad is not overtly
sexual saying this is a heterosexual
couple above it flashing lights with a
flag now the kid's gonna ask what does
that mean the parents might be like hey
I don't want to have to explain like
this is not appropriate for kids
I think no matter what how they would
have done it it would have sparked now
if it was just a rainbow flag or
something I don't think it would say
anything nobody would cared if they put
gay pride and stuff like that in LGBT
they then I think families would have
been like this is not what I want my
kids to be around they're not ready for
this these parents may not even be
against it they may just be like my
kid's too young yeah I'm not gonna shop
there I think parents should be able to
explain that stuff on their own timing
and kids should be able to have their
innocence they don't need to know
everything that is all at once that is
totally I don't completely agree with it
it's totally against the left what do
you mean so we we there's that video
people talk about where those kids are
interviewed during like World War II or
something and these like 10 year old
kids sound like they're 40 year old
adults yeah because kids didn't used to
get sheltered so heavily from from
reality
I do think it's fair to be like my child
is not old enough to learn about sex ed
and the birds and the bees when it comes
to innocence and all that stuff I'm like
dude I'm not saying the kids should be
in the mines they do yearn for that
Minecraft is proof but kids kids should
have jobs
children should be working and I will
say that with absolute Vigor and passion
because the left will be like liberals
they're like they want kids working
correct yes I do yeah I want
seven-year-olds in in Mom and Pop's
candy shop picking up the groceries
filling out paperwork and learning from
their parents what it is to to have a
job and to earn and to engage in
Commerce
so when people talk about innocence I'm
like dude
children should be around when when
parents are talking about some politics
I guess I mean the sexuals right that I
get as I said I somehow disagree like
yeah when it comes to the birds and the
bees if you're talking about LGBT stuff
and you're like nah my kid's not old
enough for this totally get it but if
we're talking about Biden Democrats War
Faith all that stuff children should be
hearing what the parents think about the
current state of affairs
and kids should be working yes
absolutely the children do yearn for the
minds um
absolutely true
um and there's nothing wrong with like
what you're talking about like kids that
are working with their families like
I find it
silly to think that it's so
objectionable to keep kids with their
families working and it's preferable to
send them to other people to raise your
children that that is that is an
antithetical to essentially how
people have raised families and
societies have grown for basically the
whole of humanity until the past what
150 200 years since the Industrial
Revolution thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time